France was the first country in Europe
to confirm cases of coronavirus now it's
the first to record a fatality linked to
the outbreak I have been informed
yesterday evening of the death of the
eight-year-old patient who was getting
treatments for the new coronavirus at
Bechet Hospital in Paris this patient
was a Chinese tourist from the Hubei
Province and arrived in France on
January 16th elsewhere the World Health
Organization has issued a warning about
what it sees as a global lack of
preparation to deal with a virus like
this we're concerned by the lack of
urgency in funding the response from the
international community the world spends
billions of dollars preparing for a
terrorist attack but relatively little
preparing for the attack of a virus
which could be far more deadly and far
more damaging economically politically
and socially at the same security
conference Sky News caught up with the
WH all's head of emergencies everyone
needs to become a virus fighter now it's
not just the scientists everyone at
Lobel army is every citizen taking the
precautions they can to prevent the
spread of the virus if we all do that we
win in Japan another 67 people on board
a cruise ship have been diagnosed with
the strain amid reports that the United
States is looking to send a plane to
bring home its citizens Sheryl and Paul
mold ski have been posting updates on
YouTube about their time in quarantine
on board out to Travis Air Force Base in
California and we're going to be leaving
tomorrow evening and also we found out
that we're gonna have to be quarantined
for an additional 14 days in the United
States so there's some mixed emotions
there there are now more than 500 cases
in 24 countries outside of China but in
Britain some good news all but one of
the nine patients in hospital with the
virus have recovered and being
discharged and the Brady Sky News